個ずつら4ダイエット
始めて約4日間立ちますか
別までまた送金バレたらいいですねアフだよね
どうですかどうですか結果がなっててくださいただ
俺
なかなかすごい通りずもやっぱりダイエットはとてもつらいです好きな食べ物とかお
菓子とか何にも食べれないから結構年かね
色々買っちゃうんですけどばライトとそういうもので好きなもの何か色々我慢して
素晴らしいボディを勝ち取るという偉業なので僕はちょっともう3日くらい頑張ります
どんなダイエットしてる僕にオススメの
商品を見つけましたこちらださっき見えてたよねはい痩せたい痩せたい痩せた訳せる
カップ
no nars じゃなくて普通の水だから糖質ゼロカロリーゼロ
ウソホントまじかこれねほんとすごいんですよほらもうあれやばいですよ
の清涼飲料水ディスられてますよねこれどんなのかといいますと
2の溝注ぐだけでジュースみたいになっちゃう
方のカップ怪しい楽天の売り上げが1位ですねこれマジかこれ本当だったらけっこう
すごいですよ江戸なんかですねっつーわけでみましょう普通の水を注ぐだけでジュース
を飲んでいるような感覚になれる不思議なカップ新開発のフレーバーを配合し香りの
錯覚を起こしますカロリー野党ストップの飲み物が好きな人のダイエットや健康
サポート
この素敵なカップで進学がをぜひ体感してください
ん
すごいすごい味がグレープあ g コーラストロベリーアップルでもオレンジとなって
おりますこれマジかー
うーん機めっちゃ普通
うわぁ
ううううううああああ
本当にこれマジで水がジュって感じたら僕はもう一生これを飛びます
嘘ですはい時に炭酸水準備しました
[拍手]
こんなのでいいのかなん
[音楽]
4日
シャアはい時で全部4割ましたいやこれだけでいいのかな
ないですねこれでは味が変わってるみたいです24すごいな
さっすぐいただいてみますがストロベリーからいただきます
米子はん
うん
ん
me
あ
いただきます
ません
ん
いただきますえっ
いただきます
ん
[音楽]
me
あそっかこれあれだ
に言いが変わるだけだいやとニューイ変わるだけでも飲みやすくなりますよ
信長めまいがするあれこれストロベリージュースん
いや違う炭酸水らーみたいなんで脳内ですごい変化がされてなんか
眩暈のする臭いを嗅ぎながら飲むとそれっぽい味にはなりますね花子
べしながら飲むとオーラっぽくなります
ええええええ
ん
そうでもでやても何かわからないこともないなーっ
って感じでやると結構それっぽくは誰と思いますがそうすれば匂いか普通に炭酸生組
よりかは全然飲みやすいと思います役所水自体に良いが付いてるって事かなくとなると
詰めて合わせて飲むとそれなりで美味しいのではないか貼っておきます
[音楽]
炭酸水ですねはいというわけで結構マナーまあまあマッパ
とか
そういう感じねぐらいの効果はあったんですけどもみなさんこのコップ御用意がすごい
強いです
なので多少ちょっと后様なっていきたいとかもこんなふうに見えたらショット者が
飲めるかも知れませんあの誰でも匂いを嗅ぐとゲロ吐いちゃうこれを飲んでみようと
思いますます月これもニューイが問題なので女体化聞ければとか言ってるんじゃねー
から適用してますね
[音楽]
ええええええ
ええっ
はいだけでちょっと飲んでみましょうん
[音楽]
はい入りました食べましてコーラおいしいフレーバーと白が出る匂いが混ざって外に水
ぐらいの感じなければ嬉しいんだと思います
いただきます
ん
あうへぇ
[音楽]
me
バッハ